Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Connors from Connors Clinic on your second video regarding
the cell danger response.
So the cell danger response is a normal physiological response of a cell to protect itself in the
event of danger.
So we discussed that in our first video, but the problem is that when we get stuck in
a cell danger response, because the danger is always present, then the survival mechanism of
the cell can really be our demise, and we want to get a little bit more specific.
So we spoke about how an infection or a toxicity or overexercise situation where we're constantly
damaging ourselves physically, changes ourselves, and ourselves respond to that infection
or toxicity, etc., that danger in a way to protect itself, in a way to help the cell kill
that infection, if it's an infection, or to get rid of that toxicity, if it's toxicity.
And that's all good, that's all normal, but the problem is is that when we get stuck
in that situation, then that could cause all sorts of problems.
So we talked about there's ways to measure that and to see the imbalance between the sympathetic
and the parasympathetic when we look at the autonomic nervous system, and we want to do that
with an individual.
From a cellular standpoint, what are these functions that change?
Well, here's just one sheet of functions that change.
So in the center of this picture right here, you see Bidows, Bidocardria, O2, the Oxygen ATP
function, that's what happens to ATP, what's it's formulated in the Bidocardria, Cystid and
Sulphur, all the way across that blue list, though normally what happens to these chemicals
are these reactions that take place, that the things there in the center of that chart
that are highlighted blue, in a healthy situation, the reaction is goes up.
So in an unhealthy situation in the cell, danger response, the reaction goes down, and you
could see that, you know, I've often said that, you know, is inflammation good or bad?
Well, inflammation is good if you're trying to kill a pathogen.
If you're trying to, if an acrotic basis, inflammation is very bad, we're going to see some of
these things.
So it's not, one thing is good, and one thing is bad, it's that if you're in the danger response
for a lung period of time, if you get stuck there, then that's what makes it bad.
So let's go through a few of these to help you understand.
So for instance, oxygen, what does oxygen do in the tissues in a healthy situation?
Well oxygen creates, it's the fuel for your brain and your oxygen is necessary for a ton
of cellular functions, and ultimately it's excreted as you go up as water.
So in a cell, danger response, you get increased intracellular oxygen, which causes
hydrogen peroxide formation, and excess hydrogen peroxide formation eventually leads
to oxygen-free radicals, it eventually leads to peroxiditrate formation.
And that's not good, and we talked a little bit about peroxiditrate formation, especially
when reactive oxygen species attach to excess free uncoupled nitric oxide species, and forms
that peroxiditrate, which is so damaging to your artery, so damaging to your cells,
leads to cancer, leads to heart disease.
Well, does that make oxygen bad?
No, it means that it not even reactive oxygen species are bad.
So the endpoint of this chart right here is the O2-negative, those are reactive oxygen species.
These are oxygen-free radicals, this is superoxide molecule right here.
So is superoxide molecule bad, or reactive oxygen species bad?
Well no, they're really not, they're there to help kill pathogens, but they're supposed
to have a half-life of a matter of minutes.
Superoxide dismutase supposed to grab onto that and get rid of that.
So when that's not taking place, because we're in this chronic cell danger response, so even
if I have no defects on my superoxide dismutase gene, so I'm producing plenty of superoxide
dismutase to get rid of the normal amount of superoxide that is generated through oxygen
in my body, in a normal response, in a normal amount of cell danger responses that take place
at a given day.
And if I'm stuck in that cell danger response due to a chronic infection, chronic Lyme disease,
chronic age pylori, then I don't even know what I have.
I feel perfectly fine, I don't have any disease, I don't have any symptoms, I have no fever,
don't tell me that I have a chronic infection, and then my first symptom is a heart attack.
So I have this excess superoxide ion produced, that's not good.
So again, is superoxide ion bad?
No, it's not, for a very short period of time, to have a very short half life.
But what it's produced in excess, because I'm stuck in this cell danger response, it's
going to lead to an early death.
So this week we can go right down the chart here, ATP.
What is ATP?
No, ATP remember is produced by the mitochondria through a number of genetic functions.
So through these genetic functions, going through glycolysis, going through the crem
cycle, going through the electron transport chain, you're kicking out ATP molecules.
It is inside the cell causing the cell to function.
So inside the heart cells causing the heart cell to beat, without production of that, inside
the heart cell, I am not going to have the energy for that heart to beat, and we're going
to have problems.
So in the case of a normal functioning cell, that ATP is used in the cell, is made in the
cell, and is used in the cell for that normal cell function.
In the case of a cell, danger response, that ATP is called outside the cell, and we have
increased uric acid production, and increased inflammation.
That's not good.
Plus, we're robbing the cell of its normal production of ATP, we're robbing the cell of its
energy source.
So ATP, remember, is a dentist and triphosphate, that is your little bundle of energy that
your cells make in the mitochondria of each cell in order for that cell to function.
So if the ATP, that bundle of energy, is getting robbed outside of the cell, because it needs
to fight the enemy, then it is, the cell itself is going to suffer.
In the case of a heart cell, you can see what the suffer it is.
It's going to be a chronic fatigue, especially upon exertion, because the heart just doesn't
have the same energy to pump as it used to.
Each individual cell is damaged, in the case of any other cell, you're going to have chronic
fatigue as well, but it's going to be more muscle fatigue, it's going to be more brain fatigue,
it's going to be, depending on where this chronic cell danger response is taking place.
So it's really kind of interesting, cystine and sulfur production.
That's through the transulferation pathway, if you go back to some of my genetic videos.
If in a normal functioning cell, you're producing glutathione, that's what you see above that
circle there, glutathione is your main cellular antioxidant, getting rid of extra free radicals
inside the cell, preventing cancer.
In the case of a chronic cell danger response, glutathione is used for excretion, it produces
hydrogen sulfide, which is good in a temporary position.
Is this bad, this free radicals that it's producing?
No, it's not.
This is what's helping kill cancer cells, this is what's helping kill infections.
But chronic cell danger response, chronically steely glutathione from the cell can eventually
cause cancer.
So this is where balance is everything.
So this is where I've said numerous times on my videos, is something bad or something
good?
Well, typically no, nothing is bad or good, it's all about balance.
And proxy nitrate is that bad?
Well, with it balanced, no.
But you should have very little of it circulating in your bloodstream.
When it becomes high, we call it causes damage.
So it's kind of fun to look at this, here's histidine, histidine is the precursor for histidine.
Histamine is made in the mass cells through histidine.
If your body's functioning normally, histidine functions to inhibit NF-capabata, which is an
inflammatory marker, which causes all sorts of damage in our body.
So histidine is an inhibition of NF-capabata, and histidine functions as an anti-inflammatory
chemical.
But in the cell danger response, histidine forms histidine.
So what would be the cell danger response for histidine production?
Well, in the presence of an allergen, or in the presence of an antigen.
So if there's an allergen, or an antigen present, histidine will produce histamine, capillary
dilation.
This is where you get some rashes and skin conditions of excess histamine.
But in the gut, it produces just inflammation of the gut, increased tissue oxygenation,
and just overall systemic inflammation.
That's not good.
You add a top of that, defects in the genes that create enzymes that degrade histamine like
your H-N-M-T genes, well, then you're in a world of hurt.
Because now you're producing excess histamine because of your stuck in a cell danger response.
So you've got excess tissue inflammation systemically.
And then you have H-N-M-T gene defects.
That's the gene that makes the enzyme that degrades histamine in the tissues.
So you don't, you have a lot of defects on those genes, and you don't degrade histamine
in the tissue.
So no, the cell danger response is ramping up histamine systemically means throughout your
whole body.
This increased ramped up inflammation throughout your whole body in a decrease of the inhibition
of NF-Campabata, so you have an increased risk of cancer, and you can't get rid of the histamine.
It's very frustrating, isn't it?
Like what is a person to do?
Well, there's a lot of things to do, and what we have to address is the problems, right?
There's a whole other role of things I could go over.
And we'll get to those, maybe, individually in further presentations, but I could talk
forever, and I probably lost 75% of my audience already, so let's move on.
What do I do?
This seems hopeless.
Well, you have to get back to.
You have to identify the causes.
If you don't get rid of the inflammatory response that's stimulating this inflammatory response
in the first place, you're never going to win.
That's somebody on the phone with me just yesterday.
Well, what I'm always supposed to do is, is it the priority to kill the lime, or is it
the priority to take care of the pain and all these side effects that I'm having of this
lime?
Well, let's think about it.
If you don't get rid of the cause, you're never going to win the battle.
So you absolutely have to identify and start working to correct the cause, and yeah, you
can subsequently treat the symptoms.
That's just fine, because we all want to feel better, but if you're not getting rid of the
cause, you're never going to win.
You have to support the pathways.
I'll hold this to my death.
If you don't look at the genetics, you're never going to win.
These are the people that struggle and struggle and struggle, because they're not adequately
looking at the genetics.
And please, please, do not go to somebody who says that we're supported by MTHFR defect
because I have a homozygous defect done 699 MTHFR, that's my whole problem.
When you look at the giant picture of your genes, your Bethel tetrahydrofolate reductase
gene is a tiny little fish in a great big pond.
You have to look at all your genes.
You need to do 23 and me.
That's the best test out there right now, and you need to go to somebody who's going to take
a 10,000 foot away picture of all your genes.
Not just looking at one gene and the gene that they're going to support that, because that
can be very, very dangerous.
So go to this website, go to my website, again, go to the genetic testing tab, watch some
of the videos on there, and that will help you understand it, that will help you understand
how you actually go and do your 23 and me, and then you can call and we can go over that.
But it's very important that you support these pathways, and that's the only way that you're
ultimately going to heal.
You have to fill in each piece of the puzzle, and you've got to look at what's missing.
And most people that I talk to have some very more than one missing piece of the puzzle
that has just not been addressed, and quite often it's genetics, sometimes it's other things
as well, but you want to look at that.
All right, hopefully I did worry to death, and you learned something from this.
I have a whole bunch of other videos on our website about a whole bunch of other fun topics.
At least I think they're fun.
Check them out, and I appreciate the audience.
Thanks.
Bye-bye.